In this problem, a veterary clinic burns
contaminated bedding and disposable
supplies in its on-site incinerator.
Stack tests of the incinerator gas show
a measured CO concentration of 250 parts
per million at 10% O2 on a dry basis. A
measured CO2 concentration of 8,000
parts per million at 7% O2 on a dry
basis. The EPA requires combustion
efficiency reporting at concentrations
of 7% O2 on a dry basis. The combustion
efficiency is most nearly 94.5%,
96%,
97% or 99.9%.
So the question is asking us for the
combustion efficiency.
If we search for this in the reference
manual, it will take us to the following
equation in chapter 2 on air
where C combustion efficiency is equal
to CO2
over CO2 plus
CO
* 100%.
Where the volumes are in parts per
million. So now how do we get the values
we need for both CO2 and CO?
Well, we can see that CO2 is already
given at 7% O2
in the problem statement. So we can use
that term directly.
So, we're going to write here
8,000 parts per million
over 8,000 parts per million
plus CO.
So, what about CO?
There is another equation we can use
from the reference manual as well. If we
search for gas stream or 7%
in the reference manual, this will bring
us to the next equation just a little
bit below the first equation.
It's titled correcting particle
concentrations in gas streams for 12%
CO2 and 7% O2.
Knowing to look for this equation might
not be obvious at first. You would have
to recognize that 7% O2 or 12% CO2 are
common reference conditions used in
combustion and air emission problems or
that these are referred to as gas
streams in regulatory language. If you
didn't know that before studying, well,
neither did I. And that's exactly why we
study.
So, let's look at the equation as it's
written here. It provides spaces for
both CO2 and O2. Now since our problem
is only asking about O2,
we can eliminate part of the equation
related to CO2 correction.
The measured CO2 is already at 7% O2.
And because the percent of CO2 is not
given for either CO or CO2, we have to
use the O2 in this calculation.
So to fill in this equation, we can
substitute the term CP comma D
with the 250 parts per million. Since
this is the existing mass of the
particullet per unit volume of dry gas
for CO
and in the problem statement we can see
that that measurement was made at 10% O2
but the EPA requires results reported at
7% O2.
Then we can subtract 10 from 21 due to
the percentage of oxygen in the CO. This
is how we will normalize this term to
the required 7% oxygen reporting
requirement.
So we'll have 14 on the top here
and 21 - 10 for the 10% up here in the
CO.
Solving this out, we will get just about
parts per million. This is how we will
normalize this term to the required 7%
oxygen reporting requirement.
Once this is done, we can go back to our
combustion efficiency equation and plug
in our terms for both CO2 which was
given already at the correct percent of
O2 and the CO which we just calculated.
So let's replace CO with 318.
And if we solve this out, we can get a
combustion efficiency of just about
96.17%
which is closest to our answer number
two on the left hand side.
So, yes, this problem can look confusing
at first, but once you realize that the
correcting gas streams equation exists
and that it's perfectly fine to drop the
CO2 term when the problem gives only
oxygen percentages, it turns into a very
simple two-step calculation.
And that's it.